I'm sitting here with Jacques one of
our lead front end web developers.
Hi.
>> Hi.
>> So
I was talking with Nick about
architecting a little bit.
You know, like you've got some code
it's not necessarily up to snuff and
you know you just move things around a
little bit to get it up to snuff right?
So what if I were to give you a piece
of code that's like that but worse.
>> You could sort of still tease
parts of it, you know, around and,
and sort of get into the modules or the
separations that you're interested in
and then replace those pieces as,
as you work on them.
So, if the, if the code's not
stuff that you want to keep around
separating it out means you get to
burn little pieces of it at a time and
replace them and upgrade them and
make them, make them better.
>> That makes sense.
So what if I give you some code
that's even worse than that?
Like, let's just say,
big mess of spaghetti code.
>> If you can't tease it apart, or
if there aren't good ideas that you'd
like to keep just burn it to the ground.
>> Just start.
>> Just take it all away and
rebuild that functionality.
>> Just like that.
Wow!
Okay.
So I guess you're giving me permission
to burn horrible spaghetti code to
the ground?
>> Absolutely.
You will thank yourself in the future.
What if it's worse than that?
[LAUGH]
>> Nuke it from space.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Have,
have a friend delete it for you.
>> [LAUGH] Don't even,
don't even look at it.
>> No, no.
>> Just, okay, so, wonderful.
Now you have permission
to delete horrible,
awful spaghetti code from your projects.
Huh, so you,
you actually have done this?
>> Yeah, oh, absolutely.
>> Have,
have you ever nuked
something from space?
Between Nick and I, we,
we have done that absolutely like,
hey could you get rid of all of that,
I'll, I'll replace it.
>> Oh, boy.
[LAUGH] Fantastic or horrifying.
>> Or, or terrible, yeah.
>> Terrible.
>> kind of both.
>> Awesome.
Well, thanks for sitting with me and
talking about this.
>> Absolutely.